Ich glaube einfach, dass jeder
Euro, den wir in Bildung, den wir in Kultur,
den wir in Städtepartnerschaften
investieren, für den Frieden langfristig
besser angelegt ist, als jetzt
mehr Waffen zu kaufen.
Frag doch mal deine Freunde in der Ukraine,
ob sie jetzt, ob sie jetzt
das Geld in die Schulen investieren
würden oder in ihre Verteidigung investieren
-würden.
-Das ist eine Vermischung von
außenpolitischen und innenpolitischen
Fragen gerade.
Herzlich willkommen bei 13 Fragen.
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Ich freue mich
sehr auf die Diskussion und starte
direkt mit der Konfliktfrage, mit der ersten
Frage von 13 Fragen: Sollte
Deutschland militärisch aufrüsten? Wenn ihr sagt: Ja,
auf jeden Fall, wir müssen uns
besser verteidigen können, dann geht ihr jetzt
bitte auf das grüne Feld. Und wenn ihr sagt:
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall, dann geht
jetzt bitte auf das gelbe Feld. Und jetzt
könnt ihr euch gerne positionieren. Okay,
alles klar. Dann weiß ich jetzt, wo ihr steht.
„Wir erleben eine Zeitenwende.“
Das waren die Worte von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz nach dem russischen Einmarsch
in die Ukraine. Und wenn in diesen Tagen
von einer Zeitenwende die Rede ist,
dann ist damit oft auch ein radikaler
Richtungswechsel in der deutschen Außen-
und Sicherheitspolitik gemeint.
Mithilfe eines Sondervermögen in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro und einer generellen
Aufstockung des Verteidigungshaushalts
soll die Bundeswehr, soll
Deutschland wehrhafter werden. Was für die einen
eine längst überfällige Investition in die Zukunft
und den Schutz der Demokratie ist,
bedeutet für die anderen, dass wir den Glauben
über Bord werfen,
dass wir in Europa gar keine
Bundeswehr brauchen, zumindest nicht
zur Kriegsführung. Wie wollen wir also
in der Zukunft Frieden auf der Welt
garantieren? Durch militärische
Stärke oder eben doch durch andere Lösungen?
Meine Gäste bei 13 Fragen sind
sich uneinig, aber wir sind ja auch hier,
um Kompromisse zu finden. Deswegen bin
ich sehr gespannt, ob sich die beiden Seiten
heute ein bisschen aufeinander
zubewegen werden und ob sie sich vielleicht sogar
auf eine gemeinsame Friedenspolitik
einigen können. Deswegen die erste Frage
an euch: Wo auf dem Feld würdet ihr stehen?
Grün oder gelb? Schreibt es mir
gerne in die Kommentare! Dann gilt für euch
ab jetzt, wenn ihr der anderen Seite
in einem Argument zustimmen wollt,
dann könnt ihr das gerne mit einer Bewegung
verdeutlichen und einen Schritt nach vorne
gehen. Und wenn ihr etwas richtig blöd
findet, was die andere Seite sagt und das mit eurem
ganzen Körper zum Ausdruck
bringen wollt, dann macht das gerne,
indem ihr einen Schritt nach hinten geht.
Ich wünsche uns jetzt erst einmal eine schöne
Diskussion. Paul, ich fange mit dir
an. Du hast 2016 mit deiner Band in Kiew
gespielt. Zwei Jahre vorher hatte Russland
bereits die Krim annektiert. Erzähl
mal, wie hast du die Gespräche, wie hast du
die Leute vor Ort wahrgenommen?
Und würdest du sagen, dass die Menschen,
mit denen du dort gesprochen
hast, dass die schon mit dieser Eskalation
und auch mit diesem Krieg
so gerechnet haben?
Also wir haben 2016 da gespielt in Kiew
anlässlich des Festivals '50 Jahre
deutsch-ukrainische Freundschaft'. Es war
ein toller Abend. Die Deutsche Botschafter
hat das organisiert. Eine Band
aus Kiew und wir haben da gespielt.
Und im Anschluss an das Konzert,
was eigentlich gar nicht so aufregend war,
weil es nur so geladene Gäste
waren, waren wir in so einer kleinen Kneipe.
Und das war der eigentlich
interessante Teil, weil zwei Leute von der Botschaft
waren da, die Kiewer Band war da,
wir waren da und zwei Soldaten waren da.
Und nach ein, zwei Wodka haben
wir alle über die Situation gesprochen.
Und diese Band da aus Kiew, die jungen
Leute haben gesagt, wir fühlen uns
als Europäer und Europäerinnen, wir wollen
zu euch, wir hören eure Musik, wir wollen
so sein wie ihr, also holt uns dazu.
Also es war sozusagen, die Konfrontation war
schon da und die kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung war schon da.
Und diese Zerrissenheit dieses Landes
ist da. Und ich finde, das ist etwas,
worüber man sprechen
sollte, dass die Ukraine ein Land ist,
was von an dem gezogen wird und durch
das ein Riss geht. Das war auf jeden Fall
spürbar die Situation. Ich bin mit diesen Menschen
immer noch in Kontakt
und ich habe mich auch im Vorfeld
dieses Gesprächs mit diesen Menschen
auseinandergesetzt und das Leid dort
ist nicht wegzudiskutieren. Es ist grausam,
was da passiert. Und ich denke,
diese Menschen und dieses Land, die brauchen
unsere Hilfe dringend. Ich möchte
nur dafür plädieren, ob wir nicht
intelligentere Lösungen finden,
als jetzt Deutschland aufzurüsten.
Du hast ja selbst einen Appell gegen eine massive
Hochrüstung der Bundeswehr
unterschrieben. Wie hast du
denn persönlich diesen Richtungswechsel
-der Politik wahrgenommen?
-Also ich glaube, ich möchte darauf
tatsächlich antworten mit nicht
meinen Worten, sondern mit diesen Worten hier
tatatsächlich: „Frieden kann heute
und in dieser Welt nicht mehr militärisch
hergestellt werden. Sicherheit und Frieden
sind nur politisch herstellbar.
Deshalb setzen wir uns ein für eine Sicherheitspartnerschaft,
die aus den Gegnern der gegenwärtigen
Militär Blöcke Partner bei der Schaffung
von Sicherheit durch immer mehr
Abrüstung und politische Entspannung macht."
Das sind nicht meine Worte, das sind
die Worte von Olaf Scholz, unserem jetzigen
Bundeskanzler 1987, als er noch bei den Jusos
war und auf einer Friedenskundgebung
-sich so positioniert hat.
-Und warum hast du genau dieses Zitat von
-ihm ausgesucht?
-Weil ich es zu 100 % unterschreiben
-möchte.
-Wie reagiert ihr? Ach, ihr geht alle einen
Schritt nach hinten. Stefan, warum bist
du einen Schritt nach hinten gegangen
-bei diesem Zitat, was Paul rausgeholt hat?
-Weil ich glaube, dass der. 24. Februar
2022 eine neue Ära darstellt. Dass der 24.
Februar 2022 gezeigt hat, dass Frieden,
Freiheit und Demokratie
keine Selbstverständlichkeit sind
und dass wir seit 30 Jahren in einer Situation
gelebt haben, die so nicht noch
mal wiederkommen wird. In den vergangenen
Jahren hat man auf die Fähigkeiten
der Bundeswehr sehr gern
zurückgegriffen und verwechselte, glaube ich,
die Streitkräfte mitunter ein bisschen
mit einem besseren THW (Technisches
Hilfswerk). Und der 24. Februar
2022 hat wie unter einem Brennglas deutlich
gemacht, dass die Streitkräfte einen
anderen Auftrag haben einen Kernauftrag.
Und der heißt es so schön im Grundgesetz:
Der Bund stellt Streitkräfte
zur Verteidigung auf. Und diesen Auftrag
jetzt vollumfänglich erfüllen zu können,
das steht jetzt auf der Agenda
und das war mehr als überfällig.
Franziska, würdest du sagen, dass dieses Zitat,
was Paul da gerade rausgeholt hat,
in der jetzigen Zeit, jetzt, heute so
noch funktioniert und noch anwendbar ist? Nein,
würde ich auf keinen Fall sagen,
weil genau wie Stefan richtig gesagt hat,
wir einfach eine andere
sicherheitspolitische Situation jetzt
haben. Wir haben ja immer
versucht Diplomatie, Frieden diplomatisch
herzustellen und mit Gesprächen den Frieden
zu sichern, genau wie Olaf Scholz
das damit beschrieben hat. Nicht
durch Aufrüstung, sondern durch Gespräche.
Und wir sehen jetzt in der Ukraine
aktuell, was passiert,
wenn der Gesprächspartner sich nicht
ehrlich macht und zwar Gespräche führt,
am Tisch sitzt auch die Gespräche
mitmacht, aber dann am Ende
eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung,
ein Krieg beginnt in Europa und darauf kann
man nicht mit Abrüstung reagieren,
sondern nur mit Aufrüstung. Ich bin der Meinung,
dass wir in Deutschland schon viel
früher Waffen hätten liefern sollen, zum Beispiel
an die Ukraine, um die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
zu erhöhen und so
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
Krieges zu verringern. Und deshalb müssen
wir unbedingt sicherstellen, dass uns
so ein Fehler nicht noch einmal passiert.
Und deshalb müssen wir jetzt die Lehren
ziehen aus dieser neuen Situation.
Warum bist du einen
Schritt nach hinten gegangen?
Ich glaube, weil diese rosarote
Brille, die wir uns alle gerne wünschen würden,
nicht real ist bin ich einen Schritt
zurückgegangen, weil wir die Aufrüstung
brauchen, um überhaupt eine diplomatische
Lösung finden zu können. Ich glaube,
nur wenn man militärisch abschrecken
kann, kann man sich an den Tisch setzen und kann
man dem Partner sagen: Du hast
gar keine andere Wahl als jetzt uns hier
mit der Diplomatie einen
Kompromiss finden zu lassen. Und das gelingt
nur mit einer Abschreckung. Ich wäre
sehr, sehr gerne auf der Seite der Pazifisten,
die sagen, dass man keine Waffen
braucht und dass Waffen keinen Frieden schaffen.
Ich sehe leider in der Realität, in der wir heute
leben, keine Alternative.
Wir haben autokratische Regime, wir haben
Diktaturen, die ganz klar sagen,
was deren Mission ist und was deren Motivation
ist. Die ist leider sehr,
sehr fern von unserer. Und deshalb können
wir nur mit Stärke und mit Abschreckung
-entgegnen.
-Auf der gelben Seite wurden drei Schritte
nach hinten gegangen. Paul, was sagst
du zu Nellys Argument, dass du eine rosarote
-Brille auf hast?
-Es ist nicht so, dass das irgendein Wissen
ist, was wir jetzt plötzlich haben,
mit dem wir aufwachen und auf das wir ad hoc
reagieren müssen. Wir hatten 2014 die Annexion
der Krim, wir hatten eine massive
russische Einmischung in den syrischen
Konflikt, wir hatten Tschetschenien,
wir haben so viele Konflikte gehabt,
bei denen wir gesagt haben: Ah ja, uns geht
das irgendwie nichts an und wir haben
weggeschaut und jetzt plötzlich sollen
wir sozusagen so reagieren? Das halte
ich für, ich halte es für falsch, tatsächlich.
Und ich halte es für ein bisschen
bigott und doppelmoralisch, dass man das jetzt
-erst macht.
-Barbara, Daniel ihr seid auch einen
Schritt zurückgegangen. Was sagt ihr denn
zu Nelly, die gesagt hat: „Okay, das ist
mir alles ein bisschen rosarote
Brille?" Ja, ich würde vielleicht gerne anknüpfen
an dem Punkt zu sagen, es hat ja nicht
funktioniert und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
was anderes machen. Wir haben es tatsächlich
nie probiert. Also wir sind ja
eigentlich auch jetzt in der Situation,
weil wir jahrzehntelang eine Außenpolitik
gemacht haben, die eben massiv
setzt auf auf Dominanz, auf eben staatliche
Sicherheit, die gestärkt wird durch
militärische Strukturen. Natürlich haben
wir internationale Zusammenarbeit
und Diplomatie und haben das betrieben,
aber wir haben irgendwie in Syrien
und in so vielen anderen Konflikten gesehen,
wie sich Aggressoren verhalten.
Und wir haben darauf nicht reagiert
mit einer massiven Stärkung von ziviler
Krisenprävention beispielsweise. Wir haben
da auf ganz viele Mittel, die uns
zur Verfügung stehen würden,
nicht zugegriffen. So viele
Menschenrechtsorganisationen haben
beispielsweise auch so lange schon
gewarnt vor einer weiteren Eskalation
dieser Situation. Und man kann jetzt
nicht denjenigen sagen, dass wir eine rosarote
Brille auf hatten, wenn wir diese rosarote
Brille nie umgesetzt haben, sozusagen.
Ich glaube, wichtig ist
anzuerkennen, dass uns Abschreckung und Aufrüstung
auch in der Vergangenheit
nicht mehr Sicherheit gebracht hat.
Stattdessen sollten wir auf das setzen,
was zum Beispiel die Regierung
auch im aktuellen Koalitionsvertrag
als feministische Außenpolitik festgehalten
hat, nämlich anzuerkennen, dass nicht
alle Menschen gleichen Zugang zu Macht,
Möglichkeiten und Ressourcen
haben und dass uns das vor massive neue
Konflikttreiber stellt. Stefan,
kannst du verstehen, dass in der Gesellschaft,
dass Leute so empfinden, als hätte
da ein Austausch, bevor diese Entscheidung
getroffen wurde, gefehlt, dass die Gesellschaft
vielleicht nicht genug
mit einbezogen wurde in diese 100
Milliarden Euro und in diesen radikalen
-Richtungswechsel.
-Ich glaube, in der jetzigen Situation ist
Führung gefragt. Nur diese Führung
ist das, was uns im Westen, in der NATO,
in der Europäischen Union
zusammenhält. Vor Monaten war die NATO noch hirntot.
Heute steht die NATO so
geschlossen zusammen da wie lange nicht,
vielleicht wie noch nie in ihrer
Geschichte. Und diese Entschlusskraft,
die der Kanzler in seiner
Regierungserklärung zum Ausdruck gebracht
hat, das ist die Führung, die wir jetzt
brauchen in dieser Situation. Ich höre
gerade Führung, ich höre Stärke. Gab
es überhaupt eine parlamentarische Debatte
im Vorfeld? Was man so liest ist,
dass nicht mal große Teile der SPD wirklich
eingeweiht war in diesen Entschluss.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben es hier
mit einer Hinterzimmerpolitik zu tun,
mit einer... Du gehst einen Schritt zurück.
Ich glaube, die FDP war
eingeweiht. Aber ich frage mich: Gab es sozusagen
eine parlamentarische und wirklich
eine öffentliche Debatte über das,
was da beschlossen wurde? Ich denke,
so ein großer Schritt, der unser Land massiv
in eine andere Zukunft führt,
die sicherlich meine Generation,
eine Generation danach noch viel
mehr ausbaden müssen, als die wie wir jetzt
hier stehen. Das muss diskutiert
werden, das kann man nicht einfach mal eben so
an einem Sonntag, während draußen in Berlin
eine riesige Anti-Kriegs-Demo über
-die Straßen läuft beschließen.
-Franziska, du bist einen Schritt nach
hinten gegangen. Stimmst du Paul nicht
zu? Ich glaube, dass es total wichtig ist -
Da würde ich jetzt wieder einen
kleinen Schritt auf dich zugehen - So einen
halben, dass wir Bürgerinnen
und Bürger mitnehmen
und dass es eine parlamentarische
Debatte gibt. Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Aber
die wird es ja geben. Das war
jetzt eine Absichtserklärung, einen Plan,
den die Regierung vorgelegt hat, das hat
nichts mit Hinterzimmerpolitik zu tun,
sondern das ist eine Erklärung, die jetzt
ja groß diskutiert wird. Ich meine,
wir stehen gerade hier und debattieren
genau das. Das zeigt ja, dass es keine
Hinterzimmerpolitik ist, sondern eben
ein Angebot, einen Plan, der vorgelegt wird,
den wir jetzt alle hier
gemeinschaftlich diskutieren. Wir sind nur nicht
der Bundestag. Also nicht
verwechseln. Daniel, du bist einen Schritt
-auf Franziska zugegangen. Warum?
-Ich muss einen Schritt nach vorne tun,
wenn du sagst, die Gesellschaft
muss darüber debattieren, über den Krieg
und über das, was jetzt an Maßnahmen
kommt. Aber genau das hat Olaf Scholz ja
nicht getan und nicht zugelassen. Es wurden
Fakten geschaffen, es wurden 100
Milliarden Euro in den Raum gestellt.
Das ist ein ganz klares Zeichen in Richtung
der Ambitionen, die Deutschland in der NATO
hat. Und es wurde auch sofort
angekündigt, das 2 %
Ziel, vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt
in den Verteidigungsausgaben zu stecken,
der NATO auch noch über zu erfüllen.
Das ist eine komplette Debatte
vorweggenommen, wobei noch gar nicht
entschieden ist, was beschafft wird
aus diesen 100 Milliarden. Und wir haben seit
Jahren die Diskussion, dass Deutschland
das 2 % Ziel der NATO erfüllen soll.
Und das tut Deutschland jetzt als Reaktion
auf den Krieg. Das hätte völlig
ausgereicht. Aber jetzt diese 100
Milliarden in den Raum zu stellen,
das sorgt dafür, dass in den nächsten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten Menschen
oder andere Länder auf uns zukommen
werden und das dann auch einfordern werden.
Ich habe in insgesamt vier
Auslandseinsätzen der Bundeswehr
die Wirkung von Waffen im Kriegs- und Krisengebiet
erlebt und gesehen. Das hat
mich zum Pazifisten gemacht. Krieg
darf immer nur das allerletzte Mittel sein.
Pazifismus bedeutet, dass wir weiterhin
nach einer friedlichen Lösung suchen,
die Politik leider sehr früh
aufgibt, sobald sie sich für den Krieg bereit
-erklärt.
-Nelly, was sagst du denn zu dem Punkt, den
Daniel gerade angeführt hat? Kannst du
diese Überrumpelung, sag ich jetzt mal so
-salopp, ganz grundsätzlich verstehen?
-Also ich glaube, wir haben ein riesen
Kommunikationsproblem, weil wir von Aufrüstung
sprechen. Aber es geht ja
um die Verteidigung, auch um die Verteidigung
der westlichen,
liberalen Werte einer Demokratie, die wir in Deutschland
sicherstellen müssen,
weil wir auch in Deutschland uns vor einem
ballistischen Angriff schützen müssen,
weil wir in Städten wie Berlin,
Hamburg und München einfach nicht sicher sind.
Und plötzlich rückt der Krieg ja ein wenig
näher und das wird etwas unbequemer.
Und dieses Statement Aufrüstung
kann ja auch in vielen anderen Aspekten
von Verteidigung gesehen werden.
Und ich glaube, dass dieser Punkt einfach
sehr wichtig ist und einfach
nicht genug thematisiert wird.
Woher weißt du denn, dass Berlin
aktuell gefährdet ist?
Ich sage es mal so: Eine Bundeswehr,
eine starke Bundeswehr ist für mich
wie eine Krankenversicherung. Ich will
die beste Krankenversicherung abschließen
und will sie aber absolut nicht in Anspruch
nehmen. Und wenn wir das nicht
haben, dann ist es meiner
Meinung nach einfach fahrlässig.
Lass uns doch mal ganz kurz auf dieses konkrete
Szenario darauf mal gucken.
Stefan, du bist ja Soldat und hast
einen guten Einblick in den Zustand
der Bundeswehr. Der Inspektor
des deutschen Heeres, Alfons Meister,
erklärte nach der russischen Invasion,
dass die Bundeswehr eigentlich nur bedingt
einsatzbereit sei und dass sie dringend
Geld brauche. Was sagst du denn?
Hätten wir uns mit der deutschen
Bundeswehr in einem ähnlichen Szenario
wie in der Ukraine gerade,
hätten wir uns da verteidigen können.
Was der Inspekteur des Heeres
gemacht hat, ist eine Defizitanalyse
in sehr drastischen Worten. Die hat
er hingelegt der Politik und die ist
nach meiner Bewertung zutreffend.
Deswegen würde ich auch nicht von Aufrüstung
sprechen, sondern von einer sachgerechten
Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr.
Die Großverbände der Landstreitkräfte
sind nicht voll ausgerüstet. Das heißt
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten, die jetzt
an der Ostflanke des Bündnisgebietes
in den Einsatz gehen, um die Alliierten
dort zu sichern, gegen die Bedrohung
von Russland, müssen sich aus den gesamten
Streitkräften ihre Ausrüstung,
ihr Material zusammensuchen. Und wir müssen
in die Lage kommen, dass jeder
Soldat in jeder Brigade, in jeder
Division der Landstreitkräfte über das Material
verfügt, was er für diesen Auftrag
braucht. Und das ist zurzeit nicht
-sichergestellt.
-Okay, also ganz kurze Verständnisfrage,
die Konsequenz daraus ist: Wir brauchen
mehr Geld. Meiner Meinung nach.
Wir brauchen mehr Geld, um eine sachgerechte
Ausrüstung vorzunehmen.
Dass es in den letzten
Jahren nicht richtig geschehen.
-Deutschland hat.
-Darf ich einhaken?
-Ja.
-Ich habe, als ich auf der Fahrt hier
hingefahren bin, beim
Finanzministerium mal nachgeschaut, Finanzministerium.
Die nette Seite kann man mal
gucken, transparente Daten 2021,
wurden ausgegeben, 46,93
Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr. Das ist
eine Steigerung von 1,3 % im Vergleich
zum Jahr 2020. Plus 100 Milliarden,
jetzt Sondervermögen, die in irgendeinem,
weiß ich nicht wo gefunden worden,
in irgendeinem Schuhkarton im Ministerium,
die jetzt plötzlich auftauchen. Plus
wenn man das 2 % Ziel erfüllt, wären
das also 67 Milliarden jährlich plus 100
Milliarden insgesamt 167 Milliarden
Euro. Das scheint mir nicht so wenig zu sein,
wenn man mal vergleicht, wie viel
andere Ministerien bekommen haben.
Alles offizielle Quellen im Finanzministerium,
die 2021, Bildung,
Wissenschaft, Forschung 28,98
Milliarden, Gesundheit 16,95 Milliarden,
Wohnungswesen, Städtebau 2,7
Milliarden, Ernährung, Landwirtschaft 1,95 Milliarden.
Wir erinnern uns an die Summe von gerade
Bundeswehr mit 100 Milliarden plus 2 %
Erfüllung 167
Milliarden. Ist das zu wenig?
Wie viel würdest du denn ausgeben
für europäische Sicherheit und Frieden?
Das ist eine absolute Fangfrage und die Gelder
werden seit 2014 permanent erhöht.
Offensichtlich hat die Erhöhung aber
nicht dazu beigetragen, diesen Krieg jetzt
zu verhindern. Sollen wir noch mehr
erhöhen? Und wir haben doch die Situation,
dass auch im letzten Jahr und in den Jahren
davor Teile des Bundeswehretats
überhaupt nicht abgerufen worden sind,
weil die Bundeswehr gar nicht in der Lage
war, diesen Etat, den sie jetzt schon
hat, sinnvoll zu verwenden. Da wurden dann
Rüstungsprojekte nicht zeitgerecht
fertig, das Geld konnte einfach nicht richtig
genutzt werden. Also man muss
vielleicht noch mal sozusagen erklären zu den 100
Milliarden sagen, dass das 2 % Ziel und die 100
Milliarden gegenseitig angerechnet
werden. Das heißt, die 100 Milliarden
werden in der jetzigen Legislaturperiode
dazu genutzt, jährlich einen Etat
zu haben, der ungefähr bei 2 % liegt.
Und das ist deswegen so wichtig, dass irgendwie
die mittelfristige Finanzplanung
Sicherheit bietet für Rüstungsprojekte,
für die Beschaffung von Rüstungsprojekten,
die eben deutlich komplexer sind als die Beschaffung
einer neuen Küche zu Hause,
die wesentlich schwieriger
sind in der Planung und dann sozusagen
in der Umsetzung. Und deswegen ist
die mittelfristige Finanzplanung so wichtig.
Also 100 Milliarden gibt es, das ist
richtig, aber die werden auf das 2 % Ziel
-angerechnet.
-Wenn ich das aber richtig verstehe, wäre
das Verteidigungsministerium, um es mal
so zu nennen, danach das zweitstärkste
Ministerium in den Finanzen. Das ist
doch irgendwie, also ich glaube einfach,
dass jeder Euro, den wir in Bildung,
die wir in Kultur,
den wir in Städtepartnerschaften
investieren, für den Frieden langfristig
besser angelegt ist, als jetzt
mehr Waffen zu kaufen.
Frag doch mal deine Freunde in der Ukraine,
ob sie jetzt, ob sie jetzt
das Geld in die Schulen investieren
würden oder um in ihre Verteidigung investieren
-würden.
-Das ist eine Vermischung von
außenpolitischen und innenpolitischen
Fragen gerade.
-Aber das Budget ist ja da.
-Das stimmt doch nicht, wie du die
Ministerien gegenseitig
aufgerechnet hast, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, aber was die Leute wie ich und Leute
da draußen jetzt angucken, die können sich
gar nicht vorstellen, was 1
Milliarde ist. Die können sich noch viel weniger
vorstellen, was 100 Milliarden
sind. Deswegen habe ich die anderen Zahlen
aufgeführt, damit man mal sieht,
inwiefern sozusagen die Relation ist zu dem,
was dann auf dem Tisch liegt. Und wir Leute,
die noch jünger sind als ich,
die hören die ganze Zeit: Ja ach, den Klimawandel
haben wir echt nicht so viel
und das wird echt schwer. Da müssen
wir die Bevölkerung wirklich auf sehr hohe
Investitionen vorbereiten. Da wird
alles irgendwie sehr vorsichtig angefasst.
Jetzt plötzlich tauchen von irgendwoher
diese 100 Milliarden Euro auf.
Ich knüpfe da mal an. Deutschland hat
mit knapp 53 Milliarden Dollar 2020 den siebt
größten Verteidigungshaushalt weltweit.
Zum Vergleich Russland, weil du Vergleiche
magst, Paul, Russland gab nur 9
Milliarden Dollar für das Militär aus, also Russland
9 Milliarden, wir 53 Milliarden
Dollar. Wo ging denn das ganze Geld
in der Vergangenheit hin, Stefan?
Also hat das nicht gereicht. Ganz doof naiv
gefragt. Irgendwie muss
man es ja verstehen können.
Also in den letzten Jahren, ich muss
sagen Jahrzehnten, hatten wir das,
was wir Friedensdividende nennen.
Das heißt, wir hatten deutlich höhere
Verteidigungsausgaben vor 1990, und wir hatten
auch deutlich gefülltere Depots
und Waffensysteme in den Streitkräften.
Dann war der Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs
und der Glaube war der ewige Friede
bricht aus und wir haben eingespart. Und zwar
massiv eingespart, auf Kosten der Streitkräfte,
auf Kosten der Bundeswehr.
Und das fällt uns jetzt auf die Füße.
Und wir müssen jetzt etwas aufholen,
was wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten
sträflich vernachlässigt haben und müssen
die Bundeswehr ausrüsten
und deswegen stehen wir da.
Aber es geht jetzt um die 53
Milliarden, die wir bereits hatten. Warum hat
-dieses Geld nicht gereicht?
-Es hat nicht gereicht, um den
Standardstand zu haben, der jetzt
notwendig wäre, um glaubwürdig einen
Gegner und das ist ja die Russische
Föderation seit dem 24.02 ganz offenbar
abzuschrecken davor, uns
anzugreifen. Und der Grund, dass sozusagen wir nicht
die Ukraine heute sind, das ist NATO
und das ist EU und wir müssen glaubwürdig
sein in der Abschreckung gegenüber
der Russischen Föderation, damit wir nicht
-angegriffen werden.
-Was habt ihr denn gedacht, als ihr gehört
habe, dass wir in der Zukunft sehr stark
in die Bundeswehr investieren wollen?
Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare!
Barbara, kannst du das verstehen,
dass die 53 Milliarden nicht
ausgereicht haben zur Abschreckung? Ich finde,
das knüpft quasi an so ein bisschen
an die ursprüngliche Frage von vorhin,
was eigentlich quasi diese Zeitenwende
ausmacht, weil sich ja schon die Frage
stellt: Was für eine Aufgabe hat
die Bundeswehr? Was soll die Bundeswehr
erfüllen und was wollen wir sozusagen
mit dem Budget erfüllen? Und all diese Fragen
sind halt auch noch nicht
umfänglich beantwortet oder diskutiert.
Und das heißt, eigentlich brauchen wir dafür,
bevor wir substanziell investieren,
zum einen theoretisch eine Debatte
wofür eigentlich? Plus, es gibt massiv Kritik
an den Beschaffungsstrukturen,
massiv Kritik an der Effizienz, die dahinter
steht. Und die Frage ist zum einen:
Hilft dann mehr Geld, wenn wir sowieso schon
eigentlich gerade das Beschaffungsamt
in der Kritik steht. Und auf der anderen
Seite ist ja schon der Punkt, dass man
es vergleichen muss mit anderen Budgets
und mit den Budgets anderer
Ministerien, weil natürlich wir nicht
diesen Unterschied machen können
zwischen das eine ist Investition und Frieden
und das andere ist Investitionen in die Küche
zu Hause. Also, um dieses Bild
aufzugreifen, weil wir natürlich
irgendwie, um in Frieden zu investieren,
in Diplomatie investieren müssen,
in Entwicklungszusammenarbeit investieren
müssen. Und die Budgets sind in dem Haushalt
2022 gerade kleiner angesetzt
als im Jahr davor. Und das kann
halt nicht sein im Verhältnis zu uns.
Nochmal zur Einordnung: Das Sondervermögen
ist gerade dazu geeignet, dass es nicht
passiert, weil das Sondervermögen
sind de facto Schulden, die wir aufnehmen,
die aber dazu führen, dass kein
anderes Ressort jetzt weniger sozusagen Mittel
zur Verfügung hat. So, und diesen Diskussionsprozess,
den führen
wir auch im Koalitionsvertrag,
steht drin: Diskussion einer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie und im ersten
Jahr nach Regierungsantritt wird ein Papier
dastehen mit genau diesen Fragen, die viel
weiter sind als nur auf den engen Umfang
der Bundeswehr. Also da geht es auch um die Punkte,
die du gerade angesprochen
hast. Die werden da alle
abgebildet in diesem Dokument.
Aber es geht ja genauso um die Investitionen,
beispielsweise eben
in Haushalte für das Entwicklungsministerium,
für das Auswärtige Amt und die Haushalte
sind kleiner angesetzt als in den Jahren
davor. Also ich verstehe die Logik
hinter dem Sonderposten oder die Argumentation.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher,
ob das verlässlich ist, wenn quasi
in der jetzigen Haushaltsdebatte
schon ein anderer Eindruck entsteht.
Und gleichzeitig müssen wir einfach
über diese Trennung oder wir müssen eigentlich
darüber hinwegkommen zu sagen, das eine sind
Ausgaben in Sicherheit, damit
wir sozusagen unsere Lebensgrundlagen
sichern können und dann können wir uns
um alles andere kümmern, weil das zum Beispiel
auch einhergeht
mit den Herausforderungen, die wir haben,
wie zum Beispiel Klimawandel etc.
und dafür müssen wir eigentlich
auch investieren. Und natürlich stellt sich
die Frage, wofür das Geld
da und wofür nicht.
-Oh, ihr geht einen Schritt auf sie zu.
-Also ich sage ja, die Budgets müssen
weiter in Bildung und Gesundheit
fließen. Das ist gar keine Frage. Das soll ja
auch nicht aus diesen Töpfen genommen
werden. Deswegen bin ich gerade ein Stück
vorgegangen, einen Schritt
vorgegangen, weil ich einfach sehe, dass das ein Thema
ist, was wichtig ist und was auch weiter
thematisiert werden muss. Ich glaube aber
trotzdem, dass das Thema
Sondervermögen für eine Aufrüstung oder eben neue
-Ausrüstung hier gar kein Paradox gibt.
-Daniel, ich würde gerne dich ansprechen.
Du warst zehn Jahre lang Soldat
bei der Bundeswehr. Du bist aber trotzdem
auf der gelben Seite des
Feldes und gegen eine Aufrüstung. Warum?
Ich habe in Afghanistan und auch im Kosovo
gesehen, dass Aufrüstung nicht dazu führt,
dass es friedlicher wird. Ich kam 2005
in einem relativen Frieden in Afghanistan an,
und dieser Frieden, dieser relative
Frieden ist über die nächsten Jahre
erodiert. Es wurde immer
kriegerischer, es gab immer mehr Auseinandersetzungen.
Man hat in Afghanistan das Militär
aufgerüstet und die Streitkräfte
ausgestattet. Und letztendlich
gelangte man an den Punkt, dass all das nicht
geholfen hat. Ich habe nicht
gesehen, dass diese Aufrüstung dazu geführt hat,
dass es friedlicher im Land
geworden ist. Und das ist für mich etwas,
was ich vor Ort sehr persönlich
erfahren habe und weswegen ich sage: Nein,
Aufrüstung kann nicht das Ziel
sein. Wir sind überhaupt nicht in der Lage,
auf das zu reagieren, was jetzt dieser Krieg
da in Russland gerade ausgelöst hat.
Und wir werden definitiv mit mehr
Waffen es auch nicht erreichen,
dass wir da wieder
zu mehr Frieden beitragen.
Stefan, kannst du diesen Punkt von Daniel
nachvollziehen? Würdest du da einen
-Schritt auf ihn zugehen?
-Die Punkte, die zu Afghanistan gesagt
wurden, kann ich nachvollziehen,
weil ich auch...
Dann kannst du einen
Schritt auf ihn zugehen.
Ich sage auch gleich, warum ich den Schritt
nicht machen kann.
-Okay.
-Weil ich auch zweimal in Afghanistan war,
kann ich sie nachvollziehen und habe
ähnliche persönliche Erfahrungen im Kundus
und in Faizabad gemacht. Ich kann
deswegen keinen Schritt auf ihn zumachen,
weil die Situation Russland, Ukraine
eine andere ist als Syrien und Afghanistan.
Wir haben es hier nicht mit Terroristen
zu tun, sondern mit strategischen
Streitkräften der Russischen
Föderation und der Gegner ist ein anderer.
Deswegen ist auch der Konflikt ein anderer
und ist, weil Russland Nuklearmacht ist,
eben so viel gefährlicher und anders
als Afghanistan und Syrien.
Paul, ich glaube du bist
einen Schritt nach hinten gegangen?
Ich denke noch über dieses Abschreckungsszenario
nach, was du vorhin
als notwendig empfunden hast. Und ich habe
die Zahl recherchiert im Vorfeld
für dieses Gespräch hier, dass die NATO
eh schon das zwanzigfache dessen ausgibt,
was Russland ausgibt. Und das ist
doch schon eine ziemliche Abschreckung.
Da sieht man doch, dass die Abschreckung
nicht funktioniert. Also ich finde,
das ist eine Logik, die sich
mir einfach nicht erschließt.
Franziska, warum ist
das nicht Abschreckung genug?
Naja, weil die Ukraine nicht
genug verteidigungsfähig war, um einen
Angriffskrieg von Russland
ausreichend abzuschrecken. Und weil wir die Ukraine
zu sehr alleine gelassen haben. Das würde
ich schon so sagen. Die Ukraine hat immer
wieder gesagt: Achtung, ein Krieg
steht bevor, wir werden angegriffen werden,
wenn ihr nicht helft und Deutschland
nicht geholfen, zunächst.
Aber es geht ja gerade darum, dass das Budget,
was die NATO insgesamt hat,
trotzdem nicht ausgereicht hat, um an dieser Stelle
abzuschrecken. Was entgegen
-das zu diesem konkreten Argument
-Ich würde sagen, dass erstens ist die
Ukraine nicht Teil der NATO, das hat
die Ukraine, deshalb hat die NATO ja immer
wieder versucht klarzustellen, ich meine,
Scholz war extra in Russland, hat gesagt,
das Thema ukrainischer Beitritt zur NATO
steht nicht auf der Tagesordnung.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, das Problem
ist eigentlich, dass die Gegner immer wieder
sagen: Naja, aber am Ende, das NATO
Budget ist so groß und das ist genau das Problem.
Es geht uns ja gar nicht darum, die NATO
irgendwie aufzublähen oder so, es geht
darum, auf eine aktuelle andere
sicherheitspolitische Lage zu reagieren.
Nelly, wir diskutieren ja die ganze
Zeit hier auf so einer Basis von,
dass wir diese Situation jetzt gerade
als Zäsur empfinden. Annalena Baerbock hat
von einer anderen Welt gesprochen,
in der wir nach dem Angriff in der Ukraine
aufgewacht sind, in der wir jetzt
leben. Hat sie denn deiner Meinung nach recht?
Also hat dieser Krieg und dieser Angriff
unsere Welt so fundamental verändert?
Ich komme ungern auf die rosarote
Brille zurück, aber ich glaube, wir sind
in derselben Welt aufgewacht. Es ist
einfach nur in Deutschland plötzlich
unbequem geworden, weil ja Kriege auch weltweit
in anderen Ländern geführt werden
und wir uns da ganz bequem
zurücklehnen und das die anderen machen lassen.
Und was ich auch noch zum Thema NATO
sagen wollte, haben wir Deutsche uns auch immer
auf die USA verlassen, um so das eigentlich
zu tun, was wir auch hätten tun
können und sollen, hätten wir uns
richtig ausgerüstet und hätten wir eigentlich
die Rolle übernommen und die Verantwortung
übernommen, die meiner Meinung
nach auch Deutschland übernehmen
muss. Paul, Daniel, ihr seid einen Schritt
-auf Nelly zugegangen. Warum?
-Ich finde den Kommentar sehr gut, dass
eigentlich die ganze Zeit
Krieg herrscht irgendwo auf der Welt.
Und dass wir das jetzt einfach
dadurch, dass geografisch näher ist, mehr
als unser Problem betrachten. Das findet,
dem kann man zustimmen, finde ich.
Aber was ist denn dann die Konsequenz?
Was genau meinst du damit? Das heißt,
wir hätten von Anfang an früher
militärisch aufrüsten müssen,
um da souveräner zu sein, oder wie genau
kann man das interpretieren?
Deutschland muss seiner
Verantwortung gerecht werden, den 2 % Anteil eben
leisten, wie es in der NATO auch vorgesehen
ist. Und noch dazu, glaube ich,
haben wir uns einfach historisch
bedingt aus der Verantwortung gezogen und gesagt
historisch können wir einfach
nicht Deutsche wieder in Uniform haben
und ein starkes Militär. Und ich sehe
es gerade, ich sehe gerade das Gegenteil.
Ich glaube, es ist in Deutschlands
Verantwortung, dass das Bild so zu prägen
und die internationale
Weltordnung irgendwie auch so mit zu prägen
und zu gestalten als westlich
liberale Demokratie.
Daniel, du bist noch
einen Schritt zurückgegangen.
Wir haben uns als Deutschland nicht
aus der Verantwortung genommen. Wir haben
beigestanden, als die USA
angegriffen worden sind, auch beim Irakkrieg.
Auch wenn nach vorne hin unser Kanzler
gesagt hat: Nein zum Irakkrieg,
nach hinten hin haben unsere Geheimdienste
unterstützt. All das ist mittlerweile
auch sehr deutlich nachvollziehbar.
Da war ein deutscher Geheimdienst dabei
beteiligt, diese Kriegsgründe
mit zu konstruieren. Also haben
wir auch da eine Verantwortung, die wir,
wenn auch eine fragwürdige, aber im Rahmen
-dieses Bündnis mitzutragen haben.
-Barbara, Paul, war Deutschland aufgrund
der Geschichte zu ängstlich davor,
wieder mehr Deutsche in Uniform zu sehen,
-das Militär aufzustocken?
-Ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall aus
einer historischen Verantwortung
heraus Deutschland ein anderes Verhältnis
zu Militär hat. Und gleichzeitig
haben wir sicherlich eine große Verantwortung
für internationalen Frieden und Sicherheit.
Also ich bin grundsätzlich
nicht abgeneigt zu sagen, wir brauchen
eine Bundeswehr, die einsatzbereit ist.
Die Frage ist aber wofür? Und vor allen
Dingen ist die Frage: In welcher Priorität
sprechen wir darüber? Also wir haben
zum Beispiel aus der historischen
Verantwortung heraus ja ganz klar
gesagt, es gibt einen Primat des Zivilen,
also quasi immer. Also zivile
Maßnahmen haben Vorrang. Deutschland hat sich
im Koalitionsvertrag
feministischer Außenpolitik verschrieben. Wir haben
irgendwie gesagt menschliche
Sicherheit ist eines unserer Ziele Frieden
und Sicherheit. Und wie kommen wir denn
da hin? Und meiner Meinung nach nicht über
militärische Maßnahmen, sondern darüber,
dass wir uns, dass wir eben massiv
investieren in Entwicklung, in Prävention,
in Menschenrechtsschutz etc. etc..
Also das ist hier jetzt mal ein ordentliches
Entgegenkommen von Barbara,
würde ich sagen. Ihr seid auch alle
einen Schritt auf sie zugegangen.
Absolut. Und ich kann das auch nur unterstreichen.
Sicherheit muss vernetzt
gedacht werden, ressortübergreifend,
Ressort gemeinsam und nicht nur im engen
Feld der, also der harten militärischen
Sicherheit und ganz unterstützend. Das ist
sozusagen auch meine Erfahrung. Die Bundeswehr
heute ist nicht die nationale
Volksarmee. Wir dienen keiner
Partei, wir dienen auch keinem Menschen.
Menschheitsverbrechen, wie Adolf
Hitler die Wehrmacht gedient hat. Wir dienen
der Freiheit, der Demokratie und dem Recht
heute. Die Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind
schon sehr reflektierte Staatsbürger in Uniform
und darum bin ich auch heute hier,
um das sozusagen mal in dieser großen
Öffentlichkeit auch zu sagen
und zu dokumentieren. Und beileibe
keine sozusagen unreflektierten,
willenlosen Befehlsempfänger,
ganz im Gegenteil. Aber gibt es nicht
auch ein unaufgearbeitets
Rechtsextremismus Problem
in der Bundeswehr, über das wir jetzt
vielleicht auch mal plötzlich..
Gibt es das nicht auch in der Polizei
und wir wollen nicht die Polizei abschaffen?
Ja, aber darüber reden wir ja
zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr.
Ich muss auch dazu sagen,
als Jüdin und Enkeltochter von zwei
Holocaustüberlebenden sehe ich deshalb es auch als so
wichtig an, die Gesellschaft
da mit ins Boot zu nehmen und zu sagen,
wir müssten alle einer Bundeswehr dienen
oder dem Land dienen, in dem wir uns
heute in Deutschland zu Hause fühlen.
Und ich sehe das gar nicht als Streitkräfte,
in erster Linie aber
wirklich als gesamtgesellschaftliches
Konstrukt. Und deswegen habe
ich auch Barbara vorhin zugestimmt,
weil wir müssen uns das, wir müssen das neu
denken, wir müssen gucken, wie investieren
wir richtig rein. Und genau deswegen ist
-ja diese Diskussion so wichtig.
-Also hast du ganz plump gesagt, weil wir
das vorhin besprochen hatten, kein
Problem damit, Deutsche aufgerüstet und in Uniform
-zu sehen.
-Gerade wegen der historischen
Verantwortung liegt Deutschland, hat
heute Deutschland diese Verantwortung, aktiv
an diesem internationalen Konstrukt
teilzunehmen. Und wir können einfach nicht
in Deutschland uns zurücklehnen und sagen:
Wenn in Syrien chemische Waffen eingesetzt
werden, dann können wir da auch nicht
eingreifen, weil es ist so weit weg
und es ist eigentlich ganz bequem.
Ich glaube, dass deswegen Deutschland
auch wirklich eine ganz
aktive Rolle international nehmen muss.
Paul, Du bist ordentlichen
einen Schritt nach hinten gegangen.
Ich glaube einfach ganz
grundlegend, da gibt es intelligentere Wege,
auch wenn ich mich wiederhole, tut mir
leid, als selber auf die Logik des Krieges
einzusteigen. Und ich finde halt,
dass wir die ganze Zeit auch in komischen
Kategorien, in komischen,
entgegengesetzten Kategorien ja gerade
denken. Wir haben einerseits
Verteidigung, Sicherheit. Ich erkenne an,
dass Sicherheit ein grundlegendes
Bedürfnis ist, wissen wir alle. Es gibt
diese Bedürfnispyramide von Maslow, da ist
Sicherheit ein großer, ein großes Thema.
Aber auf der anderen Seite tun wir so,
als wäre Investitionen, die nicht
in die Bundeswehr geht, eine unglaubliche
Passivität. Und dieser Dogmatismus gefällt
mir gar nicht hier dieser Diskussion.
Also das wird doch nicht gesagt. Doch. Nein,
das wäre ja der Fall, wenn das Sondervermögen
aus dem Haushalt kommen
würde, dann würde ich euch total
zustimmen. Also zum Beispiel, ich bin
total froh, dass feministische
Außenpolitik im Koalitionsvertrag stand.
Fand ich extrem wichtig. Ich finde,
wir müssen auch über feministische
Verteidigungspolitik zum Beispiel
reden. Das könnte man auch mal sehr sinnvoll tun.
Da finde ich nur Außenpolitik
betreffend feministische Entwicklungspolitik und so,
ich stimme dir total zu, aber dieses quasi
gegeneinander aufrechnen wäre ja der Fall,
wenn wir jetzt aus anderen Ministerien
Geld wegnehmen würden oder so und das dann
in die Bundeswehr stecken würden. Das ist
ja extra nicht der Fall. Deshalb haben
wir dieses Sondervermögen. Barbara, du
beschäftigst dich beruflich unter anderem
mit feministischer Außenpolitik, für die sich
ja auch, wurde auch schon genannt
Annalena Baerbock unter anderem
stark macht. Kannst du mal kurz erklären,
weil das ist glaube ich ein Begriff,
den hört man in letzter Zeit sehr, sehr oft
und sehr viel. Was ist das überhaupt
feministische Außenpolitik?
Und auch grundsätzlich: Was kritisierst
du an der aktuellen Außenpolitik oder an der,
wie sie bisher an Deutschland war?
Also vielleicht auch gerade in dieser Debatte
irgendwie gesprochen macht
feministische Außenpolitik aus, dass sie eben Sicherheit
ausgehend von menschlicher
Sicherheit denkt und dass das, was im Fokus steht,
eben nicht ist, dass es um staatliche
Sicherheit geht, die verteidigt wird
mit militärischen Strukturen und dass das das Wichtigste
ist und dass danach
die anderen Dinge kommen, sondern dass das eben
menschliche Sicherheit,
also Ernährung, Zugang zu Bildung,
wirtschaftliche Ressourcen, aber eben
auch, dass diese Faktoren eben genauso
relevant sind, genauso sicherheitsrelevant
sind. Und das andere ist und deswegen sozusagen
dieser feministische Aspekt,
dass es darum geht, dass nicht alle
Menschen die Möglichkeiten zu gleicher
Teilhabe, zu gleich
Gestaltungsmacht und Ressourcen haben und dass Politik
deswegen das Hauptziel haben
muss, eben das zu ändern, weil in eben
diesen strukturellen Ungleichheiten
eben wahnsinnig viel Konfliktpotenzial liegt.
Franziska, Nelly, ihr seid gerade
einen Schritt auf Barbara zugegangen. Wieso?
Weil ich glaube schon, dass es wichtig
ist, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel
wissenschaftliche Studien, die es dazu
gibt, gibt es ja jetzt seit neuestem,
viel dazu feministischer
Außenpolitik, dann sieht man das zum Beispiel
an Friedensverhandlungen, an denen
Frauen teilnehmen, dass da der Frieden länger
hält beispielsweise. Also ich glaube,
das Thema Teilhabe zum Beispiel ist
ein sehr wichtiges. Und wenn wir über
das Thema Aufrüstung oder wir würden jetzt
sagen, Ausrüstung, wenn wir über das Thema
sprechen, sind da relativ selten Frauen
beteiligt. Und ich finde, das ist
grundsätzlich erst mal sehr schade
und ich glaube, das ist wichtig, dass man
die Sicherheit von Frauen und Kindern
mitdenkt. Ich glaube aber, es ist kein
Widerspruch, weil es ist ja auch im Sinne
von zum Beispiel Müttern, von Frauen,
von Kindern, dass eine gewisse
Verteidigungsfähigkeit da ist. Und deshalb,
ich glaube, man sollte das nicht
im Widerspruch sehen, sondern quasi im Gesamtkonstrukt.
Und ich glaube, wenn man
das tut, dann tut man der Sicherheit
von allen den größten Gefallen. Paul, du..
Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass auch Putin
an eine feministische Außenpolitik
glaubt. Ich glaube, dann wären wir ein bisschen
näher an einem Kompromiss
-oder einer Lösung zum Frieden.
-Ich glaube, dass ist ein bisschen
-unrealistisch.
-Genau.
Das wir dass das noch hinkriegen.
Aber jetzt müssen wir mal davon reden,
dass Putin wirklich der absolute
Inbegriff von toxischer Männlichkeit ist. Was machen
wir jetzt also, also wenn wir als Deutschland
sagen: Hey, wir machen
eine feministische Außenpolitik,
wie geht man dann mit Leuten wie Putin um?
Das ist genau der Punkt, warum ich sage,
man muss das zusammendenken. Also man muss
auf der einen Seite sagen, wir bekennen
uns zur feministischen Außenpolitik,
und wir unterfüttern die auch im Außenministerium
zum Beispiel,
wir priorisieren die als Bundesregierung,
aber auf der anderen Seite sind wir eben
auch bereit, wenn wir uns Gegnern
gegenübersehen, wie zum Beispiel Putin,
die damit gar nichts am Hut haben
und das und einfach weiter Waffen in Waffen
investieren, die ein Krieg beginnen,
dass wir gleichzeitig bereit sind, darauf
zu reagieren. Um nichts anderes
geht es ja. Ja, Paul. Sagst du bitte...
Also, die Sache kann ja nicht sein,
dass wir quasi auf toxische Männlichkeit
mit irgendwie militärischer
Dominanz reagieren. Also im Sinne, also
der Kerngedanke feministische
Außenpolitik ist ja wirklich Außenpolitik anders
zu denken. Und natürlich ist die Frage,
wie gehen wir um mit Aggressoren
wie Putin? Und natürlich ist dann die Frage,
wir sind konfrontiert mit irgendwie
sehr harten Realitäten und irgendwie
in einem Staat, der halt aggressiv einen
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg führt, ja.
Aber das ist ja, darauf zu reagieren im Sinne
von: Wir brauchen quasi deswegen eine militärische
Grundausrüstung, um uns dann
um die anderen Sachen kümmern zu können.
Das ist ja quasi das Problem,
das eigentlich feministische
Außenpolitik auch angehen möchte. Also wir müssen
eine andere Art von Außenpolitik
langfristig schaffen. Ich habe nicht
gesagt, wir sollten erst aufrüsten und dann
unsere Außenpolitik kümmern. Das habe
ich nicht gesagt. Ich habe
gesagt: Wir müssen beides tun. Wir müssen
auf der einen Seite
klarmachen, wir als deutsche Bundesregierung,
wir als Deutschland bekennen
uns zur feministischen Außenpolitik,
und wir möchten das unterfüttern, zum Beispiel
in der Entwicklungspolitik und so
weiter und so fort in allen
Bereichen. Aber gleichzeitig müssen wir eben
gleichzeitig verteidigungsfähig sein.
Was machen wir jetzt, Paul? Wie willst du
jemandem wie Putin
diplomatisch entgegengehen? Oder was wäre
dein Vorschlag? Was sollen
wir anders machen?
Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass es in Russland
eine Opposition gibt,
dass es Intellektuelle,
KünstlerInnen usw. gibt, die unterdrückt werden,
die auf die Straße gehen. Das erfordert
sehr viel Mut. Diese Personen dürfen nicht
außer Acht genommen werden. Von denen
müssen die Opposition die kümmerlichen
Reste der Opposition Russland
unterstützen. Das wird, glaube ich,
auch zur Destabilisierung des
Systems Putin beitragen. Und das sollte
-unsere Aufgabe sein.
-100 %, ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig,
dass wir A die russische
Zivilbevölkerung stärken, die Opposition. Ich habe größten
Respekt vor allen, die gerade auf die Straße
gehen, obwohl sie wissen,
dass sie dadurch in den Knast
kommen. Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn, da ziehe
ich absolut meinen Hut. Auf der anderen
Seite müssen wir anerkennen,
dass die Zustimmungsraten zu Putin
seit dem Kriegsbeginn gestiegen sind
auf bis zu 70 %. Und deshalb finde ich es ehrlich
gesagt, da sind wir wieder beim
Thema rosarote Brille. Und jetzt
fragen wir uns: Okay, es gibt gerade Krieg,
was machen wir? Und dann sagst du: Ja
gut, okay, wir müssen jetzt die Opposition,
die so und so viel Prozent der Opposition
stärken. Müssen wir, keine Frage. Aber
das wird eben den Krieg jetzt nicht
beenden. Und deshalb sage ich: Da müssen
wir jetzt eben drauf reagieren. Und wenn Putin
offensichtlich nicht bereit ist,
auf Diplomatie zu reagieren,
müssen wir deshalb eben
-unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit...
-Sind wir nicht gerade an dem Punkt, wo
Diplomatie als Mittel ausgespielt
ist, haben wir alle diplomatischen Mittel
ausgereizt. Das wisst ihr mehr, weil ihr seid
meine Politik. Ich bin einfach
-nur Musiker. Ich habe davon keine Ahnung.
-Also Scholz war wenige Tage vor
Kriegsbeginn bei Putin, hat sich mit ihm
an diesen irren, langen, crazy Tisch
gesetzt und hat gesagt: „Wir werden die Ukraine,
der Beitritt der Ukraine zur NATO
ist absolut nicht auf dem Tisch.
Baerbock war in Russland und die sagen alle,
alle Diplomaten, wir haben alles
getan und es gibt gerade Krieg. Also ich würde
sagen, das ist die klare Antwort
darauf, was er zur Diplomatie gerade sagt. Daniel,
warum bist du so einen
großen Schritt zurückgegangen?
Ich halte es für problematisch zu sagen,
Putin würde auf die eine Diplomatie
reagieren oder auf die andere. Ich glaube,
Putin reagiert momentan auf gar keine
Diplomatie, und das liegt auch an uns,
weil wir doppelte Zeichen aussenden.
Wir rühmen uns einerseits um eine Veränderung
hier in Deutschland,
dass wir sagen, wir haben
jetzt eine feministische Außenpolitik
oder feministischere
Außenpolitik, als wir die früher mal gehabt haben.
Auf der anderen Seite machen wir aber
Verteidigungspolitik, und man muss beides
immer zusammendenken,
Verteidigungspolitik machen wir genau so weiter wie eh und je.
Der Inspekteur des Heeres geht nach vorne,
greift der Politik vor und sagt:
Wir brauchen Panzer. Der Inspekteur
der Luftwaffe lässt sich neue Kampfjets
auf den Hof stellen, um Atomwaffen
zuverlässiger transportieren zu können.
Niemand denkt auch die anderen
Möglichkeiten mit, mit denen sich
Deutschland jetzt schützen
könnte. Wir brauchen dringend Fähigkeiten,
um auf Geflüchtete zu reagieren.
Wir brauchen dringend Fähigkeiten,
um auf chemische, atomare und biologische
Angriffe und Herausforderungen
zu reagieren. Aber was besorgen wir?
In erster Linie wollen wir mehr Panzer.
In erster Linie wollen wir mehr
Kampfflugzeuge und wollen eine de facto
Atommacht sein, weil wir quasi
Stellvertreter bei der Auslieferung
-von Atomraketen sind für die USA.
-Da würde ich gerne anknüpfen und gehe über
in die Kompromissrunde. Es läuft jetzt
wie folgt: Ich habe einen Kompromiss von mir
an euch. Mal gucken, wie ihr den findet.
Das könnt ihr mir gleich erzählen.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr dann
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen oder zurück
oder stehenbleiben? Und dann könnt
ihr jeweils auf eurem Feld, also ihr einmal
auf dem grünen Feld, ihr einmal auf dem gelben
Feld die Köpfe zusammenstecken
und euch einen Kompromissvorschlag
für die andere Seite überlegen auf Basis
der Diskussionen, die wir jetzt
geführt haben. Deswegen kommt jetzt erst mal
mein Kompromissvorschlag an euch:
Können wir uns darauf einigen, dass wir höhere
Investitionen in die Sicherheit machen
müssen, aber diese nicht auf militärische
Ausgaben beschränken? Das wäre mein Kompromissvorschlag
an euch. Ihr könnt
jetzt, wenn ihr wollt, ein Schritt auf mich
zugehen, ihr könnt auch einen Schritt
zurückgehen oder stehen bleiben. Okay,
Paul ist der Einzige, der stehengeblieben
-ist. Warum?
-Beschränken heißt ja, dass man trotzdem
einen ziemlich großen Anteil
davon für Militär ausgibt, oder?
Genau, höre ich von hier.
Weil du grundsätzlich dagegen bist.
Weil ich deswegen hier
angetreten bin heute. Und deswegen bleibe
-ich auch stehen.
-Ihr könnt euch jetzt einen
Kompromissvorschlag überlegen, ihr könnt
euch einen Kompromissvorschlag überlegen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was ihr euch überlegt.
-Die Frage ist halt...
-Wie kommen wir zu einer Zustimmung?
Ich finde Sicherheit auch ein schwieriges
Wort. Das ist echt ein umkämpfter Begriff?
Damit kann man alles Mögliche
rechtfertigen. Es ist super schwammig.
Wir haben jetzt viele Argumente von beiden
Seiten gehört. Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt,
es gibt einen Kompromissvorschlag,
der jetzt unbedingt genannt werden muss,
-dann schreibt den gerne in die Kommentare!
-Es war vorhin schon ein bisschen in der
Richtung unterwegs, also
kein Geld in Angriffswaffen.
Also ich finde es richtig zu sagen,
es muss vorher passieren. Ich bin gespannt,
was für Kompromissvorschläge ihr euch
überlegt habt. Das grüne Feld, ihr könnt
-gerne anfangen.
-Also wir sind klar dafür, dass jedes,
jegliche Diplomatie ausgeschöpft
sein muss, bis es zu einer Aufrüstung kommt.
Allerdings muss die Abschreckung da vorgegeben
sein, damit wir das Gegenüber
dazu zwingen müssen, sich für den diplomatischen
Weg zu entscheiden.
Das ist der Kompromissvorschlag vom grünen
Feld an euch. Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne
positionieren und einen Schritt auf sie zugehen,
zurückgehen, stehenbleiben.
Paul denkt daran, du willst auf der Kamera
noch gesehen werden. Du bist eigentlich
schon ganz hinten. Ähm, okay, also,
ihr seid alle, Pau, du bist stehengeblieben
ganz hinten, ihr seid alle
einen Schritt zurückgegangen. Warum?
Wir haben gerade über toxische
Männlichkeit gesprochen. Das klingt
für mich super toxisch, ehrlich
gesagt. Das heißt, ich habe nur ein Argument,
wenn ich der Stärkere bin. Und ich finde,
auf diese Logik des Stärkeren,
auf diese Kriegslogik, so möchte ich sie nennen,
möchte ich mich nicht einlassen
-und auch meine Argumentation hier nicht.
-Barbara, wenn, dann noch ganz kurz, damit
wir zu eurem Kompromissvorschlag kommen
können bis zu dem Punkt, an dem ihr gesagt
habt, Abschreckung hätte schon
passiert sein müssen, hätte ich euch
auch zugestimmt. Aber das ist ja
das, das ist irgendwie die Kern Ursache
von Konflikt Dynamik. Und ich glaube
nicht, dass Abschreckung friedensstiftend
wirkt. Okay, dann bin ich gespannt,
ob euer Kompromissvorschlag dazu führt,
dass die andere Seite zumindest auf euch
zugeht. Unser Kompromissvorschlag ist,
dass Investitionen in Sicherheit zu immer
und zuerst in menschliche Sicherheit
getätigt werden müssen und dass,
wenn Investitionen in Bundeswehr
oder militärische Strukturen
getätigt werden, das nur stattfindet im Sinne
von defensiven Denken, im Sinne von keine
Angriffswaffen, im Sinne von in einem
europäischen oder NATO Verbund, um quasi
auch Kosten und Effizienz sparend
irgendwie zu investieren. Was sagt ihr zu dem Kompromissvorschlag?
Geht ihr einen
Schritt auf die gelbe Seite zu? Also
erst einmal finde ich das ein richtig guter
grundsätzlich Kompromissvorschlag.
Am Ende des Tages habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ihr nicht ernsthaft mit dem Kompromissvorschlag
bereit seid,
dass wenn eine massive
Gefährdung stattfindet, ein Krieg,
dass die Bundeswehr sich bereit
machen sollte und eben da auch aufrüsten sollte
militärisch. Deshalb kann ich quasi
weder vor noch zurückgehen. Ich hätte eigentlich
gedacht, dass wir uns auf mehr
hätten einigen können, aber gleichzeitig,
ich muss sagen, ich fand es interessant.
Ich fand es total cool, mal so gegenüber
zu stehen, die Argumente auszutauschen
und zu versuchen sich anzunähern. Ich glaube
auch, wenn man es am Ende dann
nicht schafft, hat das irgendwie einen Wert,
-dass man es versucht.
-Ja, definitiv, denke ich auch. Der Ton war
sehr respektvoll, aber war auch sehr lustvoll.
Und da sind wir auch hergekommen
zum Streiten und das haben wir gut
getan. Dennoch muss ich sagen, dass mich alles
schon sehr emotionalisiert, weil ich finde
es schwer, über diese Themen zu sprechen,
ohne dadurch emotionalisiert zu werden,
weil ich tatsächlich an die Leute denke,
die ich da kenne. Und ich denke aber,
das ist alles, was heute hier gefallen ist,
ganz gut tatsächlich widerspiegelt, was im Land
gerade los ist, weil wir im Grunde
eigentlich, glaube ich,
überfordert sind ein bisschen mit dieser großen
-Entscheidung.
-Ich glaube, es ist auch okay, überfordert
zu sein. Also ich finde, dass ihr schon
recht hattet, als sie am Anfang gesagt
habt, wir brauchen darüber eine Debatte.
Ja. Und ich finde, das könnte heute
irgendwie auch einen kleinen Teil
dazu beitragen, dass man zum Beispiel jetzt
in den Kommentaren oder so
diskutiert und auch nach dieser Diskussion jetzt
das als einen Startpunkt für eine weitere
Debatte bedrachtet. Okay, das klingt so,
als würdet ihr euch jetzt erst mal
für diese 13 Fragen Folge nicht, wir weiter
aufeinander zu bewegen. Ich glaube,
das ist aber auch komplett okay,
weil diese Zerrissenheit, also
ihr seid euch ja immer, immer mal wieder
ein bisschen aufeinander
zugegangen, ich glaube, die spiegelt
auch den gesellschaftlichen Stand dazu
ganz gut wieder. Deswegen bedanke ich mich
vielmals bei euch für diese Diskussion.
Ich glaube die Diskussion hat sehr gut
gezeigt das ja klar, 100 Milliarden,
das ist sehr viel Geld. Wir müssen über
das Geld sprechen. Aber vor allem ist
die Frage, die wir uns hier eigentlich stellen
müssen. Was wollen wir überhaupt?
Was wollen wir sicherheitspolitisch
für eine Rolle einnehmen
weltweit? Aber was wollen wir auch konkret
von der Bundeswehr? Was für Aufgaben
soll sie übernehmen, welche nicht? Und das ist,
glaube ich, eine Diskussion, die wir wahrscheinlich
noch viele, viele weitere
Male führen müssen und auch breit
gesellschaftlich und das hat uns,
glaube ich, diese Folge 13 Fragen sehr gut
gezeigt. Wenn euch diese 13 Fragen Folge
gefallen, wenn sie euch bereichert
hat, dann freuen wir uns sehr, wenn ihr uns
ein Abo da lasst, das könnt ihr hier
machen. Hier oben gibt es ein weiteres
Video von 13 Fragen und hier unten ein
weiteres Video zum Thema.